so I was very excited when I learned
about the new Fox show Gotham a gritty
serial drama about Batman great idea but
it turns out it's not about Batman
Batman doesn't even appear in it it's
about Bruce Wayne's childhood sorry shut
up I mean do we really need a show about
rookie cop James Gordon solving the
murder of Bruce Wayne's parents and
witnessing the origin stories of all of
the Batman villains we don't get to see
Bruce become Batman but we do get to see
Oswald Cobblepot become the penguin
I confess them that poor orphan boy
pricked my conscience that's small
consolation this is like a prequel to a
prequel and I've already made my
feelings about prequels quite clear
first DC gave us an adolescent priest
Superman in Smallville and now now this
I mean what's next to show about Green
Lantern's mother taking Lamaze classes
or or a show about Clark Kent's
grandfather homesteading in the Kansas
Territory do they expect well I swear I
am shipping you off to Arkham orphanage
but maybe I should reserve judgment
the Gotham Pilot is garnering some
surprisingly positive responses it's by
the guy who made Rome in The Mentalist
and I guess DC has a solid TV track
record employ arrow is very entertaining
this new flash show looks promising
human target totally underrated Teen
Titans go is awesome Robin
yeah only Wonder see why is Marvel doing
so well with its multiple film
franchises and failing so hard with
overblown under interesting agents of
shield shield I should carry shield
shield government well DC is rocking it
with TV shows I think it's clear the DC
benefits from the institutional
knowledge gained from creating the most
compelling superhero series that has
ever been on TV holy timeless
tongue-in-cheek classic Batman see
superheroes are supposed to be fun watch
and learn kid see if you punch bad guys
just right the starburst appearances
powers zap BAM please don't grow up to
be a brooding gothy emote I'd be like
this what comic would you like to see
turned into a dark gritty TV show I'm
holding out for a stroll city let me
know your pick in the comments and
subscribe to the wired Channel
you